salut bienvenue dans la vidéo mentalisme
dans la rue 3 je suis extrêmement
content aujourd'hui parce qu'on est à la
rochelle ma ville natale et on va
parcourir les rues de la rochelle pour
vous faire des trucs qui vont vous faire
des choses comme ça par exemple
et bravo à vous comme à chaque fois
qu'on fait du mentalisme dans la rue il
y aura un petit tour récurrent un petit
peu en virgule et des choses un petit
peu plus complexe j'espère que vous
allez apprécier ça et n'oubliez pas que
si vous voulez en voir plus en live la
tournée du spectacle continue je vais
être bientôt en spectacle ici ici ici
ici ici non pas ici loïc ça c'est ton
instagram donc ça n'a rien à voir
tu arrêtes avec ça bref si le concept
vous plaît n'oubliez pas de cliquer
cette vidéo oui ma vie swingue nampala
non à berlin de la casa n'est pas mal
non plus sylvain du rif voilà c'est ça
ah bah merci contre loïc un générique
sont donc avec pierre pas du tout et au
mexique
nous sommes donc avec théo qui a
coiffeur dans cinq minutes
hockey et j'ai dit on va essayer de
faire un truc très très rapidement
ensemble avec un rubik's cube je le pose
est ici sur le sol pour l'instant le
rubik's cube les gens le font toujours
très très très vite et donc pour les
vraiment les départager en championnat
du monde
on a des cartes comme ça tu vois et ils
empochent une au hasard et ils doivent
faire la figure été dessinés comme ça le
plus rapidement possible parmi toutes
ses cartes
voilà il y en ait qu'une trentaine y en
a beaucoup plus y en a une certaine de
la vraie en fait tu vas même mélanger et
quand ça te satisfait tu poses tout à
plat sur ta main comme ça c'est le but
du jeu
suspense est à son comble a été ok c'est
bon ok toi tu t'es arrêter ici à la fin
de ton mélange on est bien d'accord si
tu t'étais arrêter une carte après ça
aurait été différent une carte après ça
aurait été différent une autre carte
après ça aurait été encore différent tu
vois ce que je veux dire encore après
sera encore été différent je peux aller
jusqu'au bout c'est pour avoir un peu
l'image mais toi qui tu as arrêté sur
celle ci ok et là tu dis oui mais ça ne
correspond pas du tout à ma carte
segment du coup tu as tout à fait raison
mais en même temps j'ai envie de te dire
la suivante ne correspondait pas non
plus à cette carte la suivante non plus
la suivante non plus etc etc
en fait il ya une seule phase que
j'étais caché depuis le départ que tu
aies jamais fait voir c'est la face ce
qui est tout en dessous du jeu je tenais
pas fait voir pour la simple et bonne
raison que c'est la même bleu orange
vert jaune blanc blanc rouge vert bleu
mais moi j'ai pas compris
est ce que ça te plait merci vous coûter
aux cinq minutes chrono
et comme ça tu peux aller au coiffeur
bonjour fabien enchanté je voulais juste
essayer de faire quelque chose avec vous
en ce moment je me remets à l'anglais
d'accord j'ai un accent qui est
dégueulasse parce que j'aime la rochelle
on n'a pas un bon accent nous à la base
à la rochelle
j'arrondis promis au lieu de premiers
tête à wall et c'est bon quand je me
fais des javanais paris dern
donc ça ce sont des cartes où tu as le
mot en français en anglais et ça permet
d'apprendre mais ce qui est intéressant
pour moi c'est qu'il ya des formes des
couleurs des choses comme ça dessus ok
donc on va faire un truc très simple
tous les trois du coup je voulais faire
ça sur plus de personnes mais vous avez
décidé de venir sans jamais donc c'est
quand tu prends un petit paquet de
cartes d'accord quand tu le prends tu
regarde la carte qui en dessous ok donc
là c'est la trompette tu vois tu la
memories et tu gardes tes cartes et
tulle et mélangera les unes avec les
autres
ça marche on fait comme ça et avec toi
on va faire un peu différemment je sais
pas encore comment donc voici tu prends
un petit rupture relève tu memories la
carte c'est bon pour toi
vas-y garde toutes les cartes et tu
mélanges ça marche
et puis on va faire différemment tu
prends une carte celle que tu veux celle
ci elle te convient ok c'est bon
tu l'as retiens-tu la cache ok on
commence avec toi alors évidemment il ya
je crois 35 ou 40 cartes je les connais
tout par coeur donc je sais déjà un peu
dans quel flow vous avez pris des cas je
vais prendre mon paquet et tu vas juste
regarder les cartes au fur et à mesure
que je devais présenter tu vas pas
cherché à donner d'indicés au contraire
tu vas voir la pokerface surtout quand
tu verras ta carte
et ce qui est terrible c'est quand eux
dix ans a battu va avoir tendance à
crisper encore plus mais comme je
t'explique du coup du va essayer de
relâcher c'était un être qui se passe
dans ta tête tu as regardé derrière ça
peut être celle ci
ok je refais est celle ci est celle là
ça peut être celle ci est celle là ça
peut être celle ci ça peut être celle là
fait celle-là ça fait celle-là
intéressante comme d'ailleurs celle ça
ne se serait pas là la trompette que
serait en tant qu'invité la trompette
hockey sur toi on va faire un tout petit
peu plus dur évidemment tu me regarde
dans les yeux et tu pense un peu à la
forme générale de tout objet est ce que
je peux avoir un calepin et 1 et un
stylo je vais essayer de dessiner c'est
pas mon fort le dessin tu vas penser
d'abord à la forme et tu imagines que je
suis en train de le dessiner ici devant
toi mais au début je fais un peu
n'importe quoi et tu vois ce qui
pourrait match et pas match et comme par
exemple le circulaire ça ne marche pas
du tout mais par contre ça ça marche un
petit peu ok d'accord alors plutôt une
forme un peu un peu un peu comme ça
peut-être avec quelque chose sur le
dessus d'accord comme ça ok ça peut être
rouge d'ailleurs spot jaune et bleu
peuvent et erp sap et orange ça peut
être blanc c'est pas beau de baisser les
yeux quand on dit une couleur qui
t'intéresse serait pas du verre des fois
je serai pas le dessiner mais je pense
que je vais quand même écrire à l'avant
ce que je pense que c'est regarde dans
cette direction pour pas être influencé
par ce que j'écris
[Musique]
c'est pas trop comment on appelle ça
d'ailleurs ok est ce que tu peux me
faire voir la carte que tu as c'est une
pince verte une pince verte oui c'est
très bon merci beaucoup
j'ai dit oui c'est impressionnant moi
j'aime fins et c'est dingue genre il y
avait plus de cartes en fin de compte
vous avez mélanger autant que vous
vouliez et du coup après vos trois
mélanges la première carte du jeu c'est
celle ci d'accord si saab était une
carte supplémentaire serait une carte
complètement différente d'accord si on
regarde celle ci quand on regarde ce jeu
vous constatez qu'il y fasse que je
voudrais pas fait voir depuis le départ
c'était par hasard parce que j'ai une
phase que j'ai fait moi-même c'est celle
du dessous j'ai fait exactement cette
phase là pour de vrai mais en fait je me
dis c'est trop fort comme est fait pour
vous c'est trop d'émotions
donc je m'engage d'attendre grecque
oui oui c'est ça on a le rouge le vert
le bleu le jaune le blanc le blanc le
bleu le vert comme ça et là ça va tu
avais une phase vas-y cherche
est-ce qu'elle existe cette phase dessus
tu sais si elle existe et je ne l'aurais
pas fait voir et c'est ça qui est
excellent c'est qu'après tu prends
n'importe quelle carte et à chaque fois
elle n'existe pas il y avait qu'une
seule combinaison qui était possible
était parti avec celui ci et c'est ce
que vous avez réussi à faire
merci beaucoup et bravo à vous
[Musique]
j'aimerais que tu choisisses un lieu
n'importe quel lieu dans le monde et
qu'une eau vive
londres londres ok imagine on est à
londres
quelles activités tu es en train de
faire là maintenant tout de suite à
londres dans londres hockey est ce qu'il
fait jour où est ce qu'il fait nuit et
jour des jours donc tu imagines tu es
amis des à l on imaginer qu'on était à
londres ans qui faisait jour et qu'on
était en train de faire du vélo
seulement à force de faire du vélo dans
l'ombre c'est plus troqué leurs idées et
tu regarde sa montre et tu regardes
l'heure qu'il est quelle heure il est
précisément s'il te plaît
regarde-moi réfléchi ne pense pas que
lui influencé je ne crois pas que tu es
libre non plus il est quelle heure 18h30
17h31 même si tu eu le temps des
changements accord ça ok donc on est à
londres
on est en plein jour on est à vélo il
est 18h30 exactement tout pile tout rond
ok c'est hyper intéressant parce que moi
j'ai une montre ici mais qui achète ce
qui est cassé depuis très longtemps et
cette montre là on regarde un a dit
qu'une heure précise
il ajoute qu'il est exactement vous
pouvez le dire visiteurs juste
exactement alors en temps normal ça va
vous frustré dure environ 48 heures et
après vous allez accepter que ça s'est
passé comme ça parce qu'ils avaient pas
le choix ça vous a plu
oui merci beaucoup merci à vous
excusez moi à ce stade de la vidéo il me
semble important de vous rappeler de
vous abonner
abonnez-vous si ça vous plaît évidemment
rebonjour parce qu'on on vous a vu tout
à l'heure et maintenant on est de retour
avec vous donc si je dis pas de bêtises
ma mémoire encore un album nous sommes
avec caroline et nous sommes avec lucas
voilà on va faire un truc était pas
prévu dans cette vidéo à la basse mais
c'est très cool donc c'est tu voulais
que je devine ton mot préféré la langue
française c'est ça ok est ce que tu peux
penser à la première lettre de ce mot
s'il te plait ça peut être a b c d e f g
h i j k l mn au pq est restée une vw
golf hockey je pensais une lettre est à
changer après d'accord si moi j'ai eu
deux matches
est-ce que je peux avoir un bloc note et
un calepin s'il vous plaît merci
beaucoup
ok regarde pas ce que je fais mais toi
regarde je veux vous dire sur quoi j'ai
match et avec mon taux de probabilité
regardez pas ce que fait vous allez
interpréter les mouvements des crayons
j'ai ça on va dire ah tu as et ça à ça
si vous regardez le ralenti vous verrez
pourquoi je dis ça
est ce que ça représente quelque chose
que je pourrais toucher dans le monde
physique
est ce que c'est normal de vouloir
toucher des choses comme ça c'est pas
trés trés soeur de manager ok mais c'est
quelque chose que je peux toucher que je
peux maintenir que je peux d'accord est
ce que tu peux imaginer faire une action
avec cette chose là oui d'accord donc
déjà c'est pas un monument parce qu'un
monument tu imagines pas faire du vélo
tube est là mais ok est ce que tu peux
tu imaginer dans ta tête en train de
faire cette action
à partir de maintenant comme les yeux si
ça peut t'aider ok ça fait bouger les
bras de les avant-bras d'accord et
peut-être même un peu les mains ok
continue le faire ok t'as déglutit deux
fois c'est quelque chose qui se mange du
coup
ok et par rapport aux deux mots que
j'avais aux lettres est-ce que c'est
global oui c'est global d'accord sa
nourriture c'est ça la nourriture
j'avais visité avec le r merci beaucoup
merci à vous bon bah tout à l'heure on
fait toute la vidéo ensemble on se
retrouve dans la rochelle serait cool je
vais pas du tout vous reparler de
l'abonnement veux juste savoir si vous
étiez abonnés instagram parce que par
exemple c'est comme ça que les gens ont
su que j'étais là aujourd'hui dans leur
ville donc abonnez-vous à l'instar g le
lien dans la description
merci beaucoup toi tu va couper le jeu
en deux et sûrs ferme la coupe comme ça
que tu coupes également le jeu en deux
si possible pas au même endroit et qui
referme la boue ok ça a été brassée par
vous deux
ça a été coupé par vous deux et on s'est
arrêté sur une seule carte celle ci
cette carte
voilà ce qu'il ya dessus si vous étiez
arrêté sur la carte d'après par exemple
ça aurait été différent la carte d'après
sort est encore différent etc etc alors
vous pouvez vous dire oui mais à chaque
fois ils changent de face vous pouvez
demander à tous ce comparatif et c'est
toujours la passe du dessous et la face
du dessus elle a une particularité et
après je sais pas si je vous la montre
parce qu'après vous allez y penser ça va
vous agacer vous avez pensé durant des
semaines on peut s'arrêter là si vous
voulez tout plein
non vraiment je vous fait voir la suite
vraiment la suite en fait c'est qu'on a
du bleu du blanc du verre du verre du
blanc du orange du rouge du jaune et du
bleu qui correspond pas du tout aux
restes et moi j'ai envie de partir parce
que ça m'énerve mais moi ça m'a énervé
ok je sais pas comment vous avez fait
merci beaucoup c'est pas compréhensible
tu te dis bah comment il est écroué
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez des pièces de
monnaies sûr vous aurez besoin que vous
ayez chacun une pièce et si vous n'avez
pas de pièces un petit bout de papier
fera bien la faire ou un caillou peu
importe je vais vous expliquer ce qui va
se passer va falloir être très attentifs
vous allez dans quelques secondes met la
pièce dans l'une de vos mains mais dans
votre dos hier j'ai pas besoin de voir
vos mains et au contraire je veux pas
les voir parce que je sais il ya un peu
des contractions donc cacher les dans le
dos ce sera beaucoup mieux pour
l'instant ça va être un jeu qui va être
basé sur le mensonge et la vérité
ok donc vous mettez la pièce dans une de
vos deux mains quand vous êtes prêt vous
me dites juste je suis prêt vous allez
maintenant déterminer dans votre esprit
si vous allez me mentir au mot dire la
vérité
vous faites le choix que vous voulez
mais vous après vous vous répondrai en
fonction de ça ok donc vous déterminez
si vous avez mentir de dire la vérité ça
doit être fait maintenant vous avez pris
votre décision
je vais vous poser la même question à
tout le monde quoi qu'il arrive
vous allez me répondre en fonction de la
ligne de conduite que vous avez choisi
ok alain est ce que la pièce est dans ta
main droite
non ok c'est intéressant parce que son
délai de réponse et si l'on qu'on sait
pas trop s'il a menti ou pas et à ok
donc non est ce que le pied c'est dans
ta main droite
non ok ce que la pièce de l'internât
droite est ce que la pièce de la main
droite
est ce que la pièce est dans ta main
droite n'ont présenté raison parce que
forcément j'ai un mélange de menteur et
de personnes qui disent la vérité je
vais me retourner quand je me
retournerai vous allez changer la pièce
demain ou pas c'est votre décision à
vous vous choisissez de le faire ou pas
je me retourne donc faites le si vous
avez envie sinon vous resté pareil
et attention dans 3 2 1 ça doit être
fait maintenant donc je continue avec la
même question pour tout le monde je sais
toujours pas si vous êtes en train de
mentir et dire la vérité et c'est ça qui
est intéressant
première question pour alain est ce que
tu as changé la pièce de mains ok ce que
tu as changé la pièce demain intéressant
à ce que touchant les pièces de mains ok
est ce que tu vas épaisse demain est
sculpteur sur les pièces de main assez
passionnant vous allez tout et tous
tendre les deux points comme ceci et
quand je vous dirais ouvre la main
gauche par exemple tu ouvriras la main
gauche quitte à faire tomber la pièce
c'est un peu le but donc allez-y temps
délai les points comme ça alain est ce
que tu peux ouvrir la main gauche
oui ensuite c'est gabriel c'est ça ouvre
la main gauche
oh oui après gabriel c'est qui alexandre
douvres la main gauche est également oui
apprécié ma ouvre la main droite
oui j'ai eu peur et tom ouvre la main
gauche c'est un sans faute
merci beaucoup merci ainsi s'achève le
mentalisme dollars 8,3 j'espère que ça
vous a plu n'hésitez pas dans les
commentaires à me donner le mot de votre
ozil et j'irai potentiellement il nous
reste énormément de ville à faire on en
n'a fait que trois pour l'instant paris
lille la rochelle quelle sera la
prochaine
dites le moi je vous écoute n'oubliez
pas de liker ce concept s'il vous a plu
c'est très important n'oubliez pas que
les dates de spectacles sont en lien
dans la description avec mon instagram à
très bientôt
ciao